okay hello everyone so I'm going to be
doing Q&A about science and technology
but specifically about things from
science fiction and I see we already
have a whole bunch of interesting
questions that have showed up here okay
the first one I'm seeing is could our
pets or other animals become intelligent
enough to take over the world that is an
interesting question so first question
is well first question is how
intelligent are pets and what does that
even mean you know because one of the
issues is we humans made a very
important invention maybe two hundred
thousand years ago maybe more than that
we invented language and language allows
us to communicate ideas in a way that is
distinct so it so okay how do creatures
learn things so the most basic way a
creature sort of learns things is
through the way the creature is
constructed through its genetics and the
there will be sort of built in behaviors
of organisms that are not things the
organism learns during its lifetime
there are things that are just built
into the way it's brain is constructed
or whatever else and we have a bunch of
these we have a bunch of reflexes well
you know the classic one is if you're
hanging your leg out and you hit just
below your knee your your foot will kick
up a bit and that's something that's a
built-in feature for all sort of humans
that are sort of working according to
plan that just happens and it wasn't
something any of us learnt in our lives
it was just something that was a
built-in feature so that's sort of the
first way that that learning gets passed
down through species is through these
kinds of just the construction of the
organism
second thing is kind of learning that
happens automatically like for example
when we're born
we don't know kind of how to see things
how to recognize objects how to tell
that's a cat that's a tree whatever else
we don't know any of that stuff that's
something that that our brains learn but
we don't have to we don't have to be
explicitly taught that it's something
that happens because of the way that our
brains are constructed and when our
brains are exposed to these different
kinds of things that we see in the world
our brains sort of automatically make
these connections it's the same way that
neural networks in modern artificial
intelligence work they sort of can
automatically make those connections
without us ever having to sort of think
about doing it without us having to kind
of go to school to learn you know how to
recognize a tree from a cat and so on
those are just things that we see
examples and we learn from them it's an
interesting question if you if one of us
humans grew up in a completely different
environment with completely different
things without you know in a on a you
know on a moon base or something where
the weather just weren't any trees
around there were no pictures of trees
there were no you know it was all very
different
how would and we did that from from you
know from birth how would that affect
the kinds of things that we know about
the kinds of things we can recognize and
so on well so that's sort of the second
level of how knowledge gets gets how
organisms get to sort of use knowledge
is this kind of their brains are
constructed in such a way that when
they're exposed to different things in
the world they sort of automatically
learn about those things so that's as
far as sort of most organisms so far as
we know have got pretty much us humans
have one very important extra piece
which is the use of language to
communicate sort of abstract ideas one
person to another without having to
explicitly sort of without having to
just sort of see those ideas and
automatically learn from them this idea
that this notion that we can sort of
take take a concept describe it in words
like I'm trying to do right now and
other people
can absorb that information I would say
by the way there's probably another
level of this that is happening with
computational language and computers and
AIS and things where not only are we
able to sort of have one AI describe
sort of perhaps even in something like
human language to another AI what's
going on but the AI can actually in a in
a computational way directly
understandable by the by the AI it's
communicating with can communicate
something but that's sort of another
level that's sort of for the future of
our civilization but the thing that
really sort of enabled our civilization
I think was the the the notion of
language and the idea that one could
pass abstract ideas down from one
generation to the next and so that
that's the thing that I think you know
made our civilization kind of come come
alive so to speak
and I think that's the kind of thing
where where you sort of need that to to
develop sort of the the sophistication
that that for example our species shows
on on this planet now this is sort of a
question so we've developed you know
it's it's very convenient that we have
you know hands that you know are good
for grasping different kinds of things
and so on we have our opposable thumbs
and all those kinds of extra good
features but I'm quite sure one could
imagine sort of building a civilization
out of you know underwater things that
you could move around with flippers and
noses and things like that I don't think
you fundamentally need you know
opposable thumbs to build up all the
things that we have in our civilization
although the way our particular
civilization has been built you know the
fact that we have door handles that work
the way they work is a consequence of
the fact that we have hands that work
the way they work if we didn't you know
if we had flippers instead of hands we'd
build door handles
you know we build doors differently so
to speak but I don't think there's
anything fundamental about civilization
that requires you know things like door
handles so it's some I think then the
question is when you look at animals
there's sort of this this question of
[Music]
well you know to what extent
have they already built up some
something that is kind of like the
things that you need to build a
civilization and could they do that in
the future so I think the the thing
well first kind of question is you know
it's it's it's a common thing not so
much in science fiction but more in just
Oh fiction books like I don't know the
dr. Doolittle books which I read when I
was a kid where it's like humans talk to
the animals you know in reality we can
you know get some level of communication
with pets and so on but we can't really
have a serious philosophical discussion
with a cat for example and the question
is is it conceivable that in the future
we could have a serious philosophical
discussion with a cat does a cat have
what it takes to keep up its end of a
serious woes are fertile discussion is
the issue just that we don't know the
right language to communicate with the
cat or is the issue that the cat doesn't
have the concepts that would constitute
a you know a serious philosophical
discussion with us we don't completely
know the answer to that I have a I have
a suspicion that it's a mixture of those
two issues that first of all there's
been no sort of sort of that developed
the understanding of what might
constitute a language that we could use
to communicate abstract ideas with
animals that's not really been properly
developed and whether sort of the the I
don't know whether it's a matter of
brain construction or whether it's a
matter of kind of of you know if a cat
from birth was kind of exposed to an
environment where there were kind of
abstract ideas being communicated maybe
it has a a different point of view so to
speak um but you know I've I've kind of
from the you know for humans we have you
know these vocal tracts that allow us to
make this whole range of different
sounds there plenty of animals from
parrots onward that have pretty
complicated vocalizations they're also
perfectly well animals that one could
imagine can you know could you know
could learn to do sign language and
things and certainly some primates have
been have been taught sign line
but there's nothing you know this in
terms of is there the wherewithal for
animals to communicate with us yeah that
there certainly is I we had a project
years ago that that never really got off
the ground that involved making video
games for for animals and sort of the
thing was you know imagine a cat you
know swiping at an iPad screen or
imagine a cockatoo you know touching its
beak to an iPad screen to be able to to
build things up we don't know what if if
you provided that kind of environment
for animals we don't actually know what
animals would succeed in building up we
also don't know if we could let animals
have a means of communication we don't
know what they would be able to talk
about like for example you know our view
of the world for instance that involves
the fact that you know we're walking
around and you know we're using our
hands to do things and my eyes are
pretty good our noses aren't so good as
as sort of sensory organs and so on you
know our ears are detecting sounds and a
certain range of frequencies and things
we have a certain experience of the
world animals can have very different
experiences like for example they can
primarily use smell to tell what's going
on around them rather than primarily
using sight and so on and the question
of exactly how we would sort of develop
the the the common the common themes to
have discussions with animals not so
clear so okay so but the original
question was could the animals become
sort of more intelligent than us
eventually take over the planet so to
speak
the answer is surely yes because you
know it's like our evolution over the
last couple million years has been no
different than the evolution of of other
organisms and we've managed to get to
this point where we have language and we
can do all these things and we can start
sort of spinning up this whole
civilization that we have and so on now
I mean it's worth realizing that the
forces that have led to sort of the
progressive change of organisms in
biology those forces pretty
much don't operate anymore with humans
so for example the the you know it's a
it's a very brutal business what's
happened in the history of biological
evolution I think Charles Darwin who
developed this theory of natural
selection used to talk about it as the
struggle for life you know you have an
organism and the organism is much better
you have a you have a particular type of
I don't know let's say Oh a particular
type of bird and the bird has and one
bird starts to have a beak that has a
particular shape and that particular
shape turns out to be much better than
the shape of other birds of that same
type at cracking open some kind of nut
that exists let's say let's say that one
bird is born that has a weirdly shaped
beak and that weirdly shaped because a
lot better than all the other birds of
that type at cracking open the nut okay
so so that bird it lives a happy life it
cracks open the nuts it eats more then
it hasn't there has a bunch of children
and it's children will tend to get the
the same sort of genetics as that bird
with its funny shape beat CAD and so the
the children of that bird will tend to
have funny shaped beaks as well and
those children will then be also
successful at cracking open this kind of
nut or whatever and and so what will
tend to happen is that the you know
those children will then be more
successful so they'll tend to have more
children and so on and the thing quickly
gets to the point where that funny
shaped beak is the thing that makes
those birds more successful makes them
have more children and so the the trait
of having the funny shaped beak will
quite quickly be the one that takes over
in that collection of birds because
though the birds were the funny shaped
beaks are the ones who have more
children and their children have more
children and so on and pretty soon that
sort of that but and the the
funny-shaped beak crowd takes over
relative to the not funny shape be proud
so that's been the the sort of the thing
that's happened throughout the history
of biological evolution on earth 3
billion years or whatever it is that
there's been this kind of struggle for
life where organisms that happen to
adapt better to the environment that's
presented to them will will have more
children on average and will eventually
take over now it's kind of complicated
because one organism can interact with
other organisms there might be a whole
cluster of organisms that all fit
together in a particularly good way and
so on but you know that that's the
scheme is the organisms that are somehow
better for the environment end up having
more children and sort of take over with
us humans and it's a feature of
civilization we're kind of not in that
situation anymore because it's not the
case that you know it's with the the
choice of number of children and so on
is only weakly dependent on kind of
things like you know if if there was a
trait of us humans that was just a
really good trait for achieving some
particular kind of thing let's say it
was important that humans be able to I
don't know I have some particular
attribute I don't know it became the
type faster let's say you know let's say
that was a really thing that we was
really important for the environment
it's not obvious that there's a
connection between that and you know the
number of children one has and things
like this so you know the standard story
of biological evolution doesn't quite
happen in the same way for us humans and
that's a consequence in that I would
argue it's actually a good consequence
of of civilization so to speak so you
know this question of could the animals
take over well we've kind of got
ourselves into a special situation where
we're no longer subject to quite the
same forces of evolution and I think
that for better or worse that means that
you know it's it's the the animals
taking over requires that presumably
well maybe maybe if we gave all of the
wild turkeys of the world or something
the ability you know we gave them all
you know we we gave them cellphones or
something we gave them the ability to
communicate with each other in some
sophisticated way maybe we would find
that with that enablement that you know
the wild turkeys of the world would
start getting together and creating some
civilization with progressively more
sophisticated capabilities and then we
might have you know then we might have a
more serious competition so to speak in
terms of you know who's creating the the
sort of the future of the planet so to
speak so I think that's it that was a
kind of a complicated answer and I'm I'm
I mean it's a sort of complicated issue
because at some level well yeah okay
let's see next question we had here was
what would faster than light travel look
like visually you know because I've
actually think that I have a pretty good
idea of what the fundamental theory of
physics might be like I've been thinking
recently about faster than light travels
so first thing to say is normally in
most modern theories of physics light is
in a vacuum is the thing that travels as
fast as anything travels nothing
according to current physics to travel
faster than light now there's a slight
footnote to that which is light travels
in straight lines where the straight
lines are defined by the the the the
structure that light sort of that space
has so if space has some really weird
structure what when light is kind of
going in a straight line as quickly as
it can from point A to point B it might
not look like a straight line to
somebody else because space might have
more certain some more complicated
structure that's how what happens when
one has curved space that's that
represents the gravitational forces and
so on but one of the weird things that's
been talked about for I don't know 50
years or so now is this idea of what are
called wormholes where you might have
space and you might have kind of a
wormhole where where there are
two pieces of space with two things
which normally are separated in space
but there's this kind of wormhole like a
worm digs through the soil where you go
in at one end of the space and you come
out at the other another place in space
and you are kind of going directly
through this wormhole you don't have to
go through all of the space on the top
of the soil so to speak you can just go
through this this this hole that the
worm made underneath the soil to get
from one place to another so actually I
have a new version of this they just
invented a few weeks ago that I'm
calling space tunnels and you know we
normally live in space that is three
dimensional roughly you know we can go
left right up down front back but it's
possible that the universe and the laws
of physics actually would allow
different numbers of dimensions of space
as well that three dimensions is just
what we happen to have what happens to
exist mostly in our universe so the
weird potential idea of a space tunnel
is something where for example you have
a higher dimensional piece of space
where when normally you're just going
through space you have to go through the
standard three dimensional space from
here to there but you might have the
space tunnel which is like a an eight
dimensional piece of space or something
that connects a little bit like a
wormhole that connects something where
it's kind of you're here in space
there's a space tunnel which is a higher
dimensional thing and then you end up in
another place in three-dimensional space
okay so with that set up what might it
look like visually if we had the opening
to a space tunnel or the opening to a
wormhole I think I don't know for sure
but I think that it would look like a
black hole on me on the incoming side
and a white hole on the outgoing side so
I think what would happen and I'm not
certain and actually this is something I
hope to actually work out is a black
hole is is something where there's so
much gravity in a black hole that
nothing can escape from it not even
liked so everything can falls into a
black hole and nothing gets out of a
black hole at least that's the first
approximation there's a there's a more
complicated story of a phenomenon called
Hawking radiation and we
things do come out of black holes but in
a first approximation things fall in and
never come out so a black hole that's
how it works things fallen never come
out a white hole we don't know white
holes exist and actually there are good
arguments to say that you can't really
ever prepare a white hole quite but a
white hole would be a black hole run
like where the movie is run in Reverse
where instead of things falling into the
black hole things fall out of the white
hole so it's a it's something where
instead of instead of you seeing
everything falling in you'd see
everything coming out so I think that in
a space tunnel what you would see is the
the incoming end of a space tunnel you
would see basically everything kind of
or things in space kind of streaming
into the space tunnel at the other end
you would see things streaming out of
the space tunnel and that's I think what
it would look like but I'm not sure and
and there's a question of whether you
would be able to see like you know a
periscope so to speak would you be able
to see the other end of the space tunnel
I mean in this current and the thing I
just described that will be a one
directional a space tunnel you go in at
one end come out at the other it
wouldn't be something where you could go
back and forth through this based on
although it's possible that such a thing
might might be it might exist in in in
space in the universe so so I would say
that in terms of things like space
tunnels um there's the question you know
how D would you make a space tunnel I
don't know maybe there are space tunnels
that could be left over from the very
early moments of the universe so if you
find a space tunnel somewhere you might
be able to use it it might be that you
know there was an old sort of old tunnel
that had been made through the mountain
so to speak that was like we might find
one from you know hundreds of years ago
or something that was unused and it's
like okay we now we can use this tunnel
but you know can we make one ourselves
the most likely possibility is that it
will be some way of taking big lumps of
matter like black holes and things
arranging them in just the right way so
that you would create this this sort of
thing that um that would exist as a
space tunnel in the universe but I don't
know exactly how it will work
and actually I I was thinking I should
try and figure that out because we now
have this theory of physics which should
allow us to answer whether these things
are possible or not okay
let's see we got all kinds of questions
here
alright let's try them how could we make
a force field that's a good and
challenging one um so what is a force
field a force field okay so a force
field in most sort of science fictiony
stuff is you know like in the Star Trek
version of the you know put up our
shields type thing it's some kind of
invisible thing around an object that
prevents anything else from getting into
that space so I might have you know a
force field around my water bottle and
it might be as and as soon as everything
approaches the water bottle boom it gets
repelled away so could we make that so
we have examples of things like that
like if you have a magnet and you try
and put the the the north end to - north
poles of magnets right you know you try
and push them together they'll push
themselves apart that's kind of like an
example of a force field there's there's
the the you know the - north ends of the
magnets they'll they'll repel each other
but of course the magnet will often if
you push two magnets like one of these
very strong rare earth magnets together
you push them together it'll tend to
flip itself around and the you know the
South Pole of the magnet will align with
the North Pole and those two things
attract so a question is can you make it
so that so that things always repel well
they're different rules for different
kinds of things so in for electric
charges there's a rule it says - like
charges if you have two plus charges
they'll repel if you have a plus and a
minus charge they'll attract so very
lectricity we have this feature that
that like charges repel charges that are
the the same sign repel charges that are
reverse of each other will attract so
one knows one other example which is
gravity in gravity everything has a
positive mass and gravity everything is
gravity is always attractive
there's no repelling form of gravity
that we know now that raises the
question why is there nothing with
negative mass why is mass always a
positive quantity you put something on a
scale it never the scale never says oh
it's a negative mass the scale
being pulled up by the thing that's
being put on it now of course things
float when you're in a in a medium like
even air for example you can have a
helium balloon that will float on the
air because the helium balloon is less
dense than air but if you're in a vacuum
where there's just nothing there then as
far as we know nothing sort of floats on
the vacuum mass is always positive you
it always when you have where you have
gravity which causes masses to attract
each other the force of gravity is
always positive it always pulls things
together okay could you have a negative
mass object actually this is something
that we can address in this physics
theory of ours and the answer is well
the answer is in the structure of the
theory and principle you can have
negative mass objects in the actuality
of making them in the universe I think
you can't and I think what happens is in
the vacuum you think you make a vacuum
you're as told there's nothing in the
vacuum well actually that's not true
that's not even true in the standard
theories of quantum mechanics and
physics that exist today in the vacuum
there's a sort of a continual activity
that is that we well we don't notice it
because we never have anything which
doesn't have that activity so if we say
let's make a vacuum we say we just get
rid of all the all the air or whatever
else then we have whatever is left over
we can get rid of all the air but but
and anything else that might be there
but then the question is is there
something that is sort of fundamentally
you know can we go even further and we
can we get rid of the things that are
kind of gunking up the vacuum the things
that gunk up the vacuum there's the
thing called zero-point energy there's
some whatwhat's happening in the vacuum
is well in in in our theory of physics
the vacuum the structure of space is
actually created through this kind of
network of points that are continually
being rearranged and so on and the fact
that we have this idea that there's sort
of a that the universe is full of space
that we can go from one place to another
in the universe and so on is because
there's this hole
worker points and as we move from one
place to another
we're basically moving one point to the
next to the next to the next to the next
through this network and that network is
continually kind of restructuring itself
and it's the average effect of that
network that is what seems like space
and space is what the vacuum is is what
we get when there's nothing except space
in the universe when there are no there
are no electrons there's no atoms
there's nothing like that
there's just whatever is left over when
all we have a space but space itself
least in in in our theory space itself
has this complicated structure in in
sort of standard quantum physics in
additions but one doesn't really talk
about the structure of space but one
talks about things called virtual
particles which are actually I think
closely related to all of this sort of
activity in space but so so anyway so
the vacuum the ordinary vacuum that you
just find if nothing is that you know
nothing is there it's still this thing
where there's all this activity space is
kind of reen itting itself and there are
all these virtual particles and all that
kind of thing okay so space effectively
has a lot of stuff going on in it if one
could somehow clean space out and
prevent some of those things that are
normally going on in space from
happening then one would have space then
one would have something with negative
mass so in other words we have could
have vacuum vacuum counts as being what
we call zero mass but and when we add
things on to that it's like oh we've we
put something with mass into it but
actually we could imagine kind of
cleaning out the vacuum if if we could
imagine doing that you can imagine sort
of you know quieting down getting rid of
all that stuff that's knitting together
space all those virtual particles and so
on then we would have something which is
kind of a bubble in the vacuum and that
bubble in the vacuum would look to us as
if it has negative mass okay so can we
actually achieve that my guess is now
and my guess is we can't achieve it for
the same reason that well it's it's the
same reason that that that when you have
heat in an object when you have
when you have all little random motion
of molecules that gives rise to heat
that the heat doesn't spontaneously you
don't get if you have a if you have a
hot object in a cold object you don't
find that the the molecules are all
bouncing around in the hot object that's
what makes it hot they don't all um they
they they can flow from the hot object
to the cold object all that random stuff
in the hot object can heat up the cold
object but the molecules in the cold
object don't line themselves up and all
go contribute themselves to the hot
object and that's sort of a basic fact
about thermodynamics that heat doesn't
flow from colder bodies to hotter bodies
spontaneously um and I think that for
that same it's an analogue of the same
thing will prevent one from ever being
able to sort of clean out a piece of the
vacuum that anytime one tries to do it
there will always be sort of effects
that just come in and kind of fill it in
just like one would get sort of filled
in by by random heats from associated
with motion of molecules and so on so my
guess is there's an isn't possible to
make negative mass um if you could make
negative mass then you would potentially
have a repulsive force of gravity so you
could have let's imagine that you had an
object and you had and you could make a
layer of negative mass stuff around your
starship or whatever if you could make a
layer of negative mass stuff it will
gravitationally not attract things but
repel things so you could make that
layer of negative mass stuff then you
would have essentially like a force
field you would have this stuff whatever
it looks like outside of your starship
and anything that is getting the air any
little sort of asteroid that might
otherwise be attracted by the force of
gravity will be repelled by a force of
gravity from that negative mass thing
that's outside of your starship so so
that's one kind of I think that's that
sort of the best way to make a force
field is to have a universal you know
because gravity is universally
attractive if you make negative mass it
becomes universally repulsive and that
would be a way to make
it would work fine until until I guess
you have a negative mass object you have
two starships both with negative maths
shields outside them and then maybe
there's an attractive force between the
negative mass of the two starships so
that makes things more difficult I'm
another kind of approach to sort of a
thing like a force field would be some
kind of something with pressure so for
example if you want to if you want to
push something away you could might be
able to do that you know at a very
simple level you you know you blow on
something and the force of the air
coming out of your mouth will will push
the thing away a bit because the
molecules are there from your mouth
they're hitting the thing they're
bouncing back there they're transferring
and momentum from that they got from
from being pushed out from your mouth
they use that momentum to push the
object away so one question would be
could you create them you know in a in a
kind of a starship scenario so to speak
it's kind of not really totally
convincing if you have this this big
sort of tank of gas or something inside
the starship and you say I'm gonna get
rid of my you know I'm gonna repel
everything by by just you know puffing
this gas out and trying to push things
away like that of course of course that
well it's kind of not unrelated sort of
the opposite of the way the rocket
engine would work and so on but um you
know so is there an alternative to that
well there's one possible alternative
which is to use something like radiation
pressure so just like you know when you
if you have molecules on a gas you kind
of you you know sort of blow them out
and then they'll they'll they'll though
there'll be a force that they'll produce
when they bounce off something or you
can do the same thing with light if you
have a flashlight the flashlight is
emitting a stream of photons and those
photons like molecules in a gas if they
hit a mirror for example the photons
will bounce back that's what a mirror
does it reflects a photon comes in this
way and then the photon is reflected and
goes back the other way
when that happens photons also has some
momentum just like gas molecules and so
on and there'll be a small force that
this photon will will put on the mirror
that will push the the mirror away from
from where the photon hits it well this
idea people have just started trying to
use this idea as a sort of propulsion
method for spacecraft because you know
the Sun is producing light that's
streaming out from the Sun and he put up
a giant solar sail made of reflective
material in space then there'll be a
small radiation pressure that comes from
photons from the Sun hitting the solar
sail and being bouncing back and pushing
the solar sail out away from the Sun so
so that's a way of generating a small
amount of pressure now could you
increase the amount of pressure that you
generate that way could you like have a
quotes force field that really comes by
by shining this bright you know this
this sort of bright radiation well the
best radiation that we know right now
would be well electromagnetic radiation
things like radio waves light and so on
could we have an intense enough source
of light or radio for example that we
can make it push objects away you know
in a really convincing way like a you
know like the the the the giant you know
space torpedo is aimed at your starship
can you can you push it away like that
very challenging I mean I don't think
that the my guess is that by the time
you reach that level of intensity of
light or other electromagnetic radiation
that you it would generate what's called
vacuum polarization which is a
phenomenon where essentially the the
actual structure in even in standard
quantum field theory this the structure
of the vacuum breaks down so for example
if you have a very strong electric field
you'll eventually get break in air
you'll eventually see break down so
that's what happens in lightning for
example a cloud has a very large
electric charge and what's happening is
it's trying to see where the can that
electric charge be conducted down
- to the ground and most of the time the
air doesn't conduct electricity but if
you put enough a sort of electric force
voltage across a piece of air more than
I think what is it a 1000 volts per
meter
I'd forgotten um if you put enough sort
of a voltage across electric force
across air the air will break down the
atoms and the hour will break up and
they'll they'll they'll the electrons
that exist in those atoms which are what
you need to make an electric current
will break off from the atoms and
they'll make this electric current they
make a plasma actually and that's the
blue stripe that you see enlightening is
the breakdown of the air the air will
conduct just in that will the air will
be sort of the atoms in the air will be
will be broken down to the point where
the electrons in them can move and you
can get conduction of the air so the
s-curve breaks down a similar phenomenon
happens even the vacuum it's called
vacuum polarization and I'm kind of
suspect that to have a level of
intensity of electromagnetic radiation
to actually have any serious effect on
your incoming space torpedo you would
end up wouldn't work because of vacuum
polarization so okay the most exotic
thing we could imagine would be to use
gravitational waves as a way to make a
so so just as we can have a radio
transmitter that produces
electromagnetic waves so when by moving
electric charges around so when we move
masses around we generate a small amount
of gravitational waves
so those hadn't been observed until a
few years ago when when there was a
merger of two black holes about one
third of the way across the universe
that was observed and in a period of
about a few seconds these two black
holes a bit larger than the Sun a little
bit with a bit more mass than the Sun
actually quite small compared to the Sun
and they they they collided with each
other and they merged and that process
of the two black holes merging released
an immense amount of energy the
equivalence of turning the hole the Sun
into pure energy in about a second the
whole Sun into pure energy in about a
second
and that's intensive but that energy
went into gravitational waves
gravitational waves are kind of
perturbations in the structure of
space-time that that sort of propagate
like like radio waves propagate in
correspond to electric Americ fields so
similarly these are little little
perturbations and grout in the
gravitational field that propagate
across the universe and they got to
earth and we were able to detect them by
these with these things this thing
called LIGO which is this basically it's
basically a big long piece of material
that when one of these gravitational
waves goes through it it just Wiggles a
little bit the ends it gets a little bit
shorter and longer at a certain
frequency and that's the way that you
detect that this sort of ripple in
space-time has gone through it and so
that was detected about five years ago
now for the first time and now these
things are seen every few weeks there's
some place in the universe where two
black holes are colliding huge amounts
of gravitational wave energy is released
and we can detect it it's really a
remarkable thing to me that an event
that is really quite small I mean these
black holes are maybe a few kilometers
across that a thing that's happening in
that localized an area anywhere in the
universe we can now detect it through
these gravitational waves but so the
question would be could you make a thing
where you're using somehow using
gravitational waves instead of
electromagnetic waves instead of light
to make your force field so what you
would have to do is you can create
gravitational waves by it by moving
masses around you you basically you have
to deform a mass the tidal deformation
which means if you have a spherical
thing it has to be elongated and then
this elongated so to speak you're making
wiggling it more or less like that that
will generate sort of minimal
gravitational waves
they're absolutely tiny for you know my
hands moving like that will generate
gravitational waves but so incredibly
small that you'd never be able to
protect them but let's say you could do
that really aggressively just like what
happened in these when these black holes
collided and merged that produced
gravitational waves there was so much
when the when the when the black holes
merge that to two spherical black holes
they merge they're eventually going to
make one spherical black hole the
process of kind of the process of
rearranging themselves to make that
spherical black hole that's what leads
to the scope defamation of mass that
leads to the generation of gravitational
waves so that that that's some so okay
so imagine we could make gravitational
waves intense gravitational waves
I suspect we could do the same thing
that you do in solar sailing or you know
where you use radiation pressure light
pressure you could do that with
gravitational waves their problem is
you'd have to make intense source of
gravitational waves I mean we you know
the only source of gravitational waves
we've even been able to detect is the
merger of two black holes and you're you
know you're a friendly starship so to
speak it's it's going to be challenging
for it to have sort of the analog of
black holes sort of lying around that
it's able to to wiggle in a certain way
to generate this some this sequence of
gravitational waves but but imagine you
could do that a question would be can
you make intense enough gravitational
waves to be able to act as a meaningful
force field again I suspect the answer
is no because I suspect that if you make
the gravitational waves strong enough
that you can actually transfer
significant amounts of momentum to
actually you know deflect that space
torpedo or something my guess is that
those gravitational waves will cause the
analog of breakdown of the air back in
polarization but in the structure of
space-time and that analog is the
formation of black holes so my guess is
that if you wanted to have gravitational
waves strong enough to make a force
field that can be useful then those
those gravitational waves will be so
strong that they were making little
black holes in the wake of gravitational
wave as you you know you you you train
your force field on something you're
generating these gravitational waves
incredibly strongly and as you generate
the gravitational waves they actually
wouldn't propagate out very far because
they would making a little by
holes instead so so my guess is no no no
luck on the force field at least I can't
see how to do it
um okay though
chants here about warp drive and and
shields at shall I mentioned one thing
about warp drive so you know that the
big idea of warp drive is being able to
go faster than light um and as I
mentioned the the its some well mmm the
way that the very structure of
space-time is created basically assumes
nothing can go faster than light so it
really has to be a defamation in the
structure of space-time to create a a
thing that is going faster than light um
but you know when it comes to I don't
know I think in the like the Star Trek
you know version of the universe I think
that the the propulsion mechanism is
antimatter and that is something
perfectly that is something that can be
you know to get the starship to go
faster than light doesn't seem don't
know a way to do that I think you're
talking about space tunnels and things
like this and it's not clear how that
works but in terms of just having a a
way to propel the spacecraft how might
you propel a spacecraft well how does it
how does a basic spacecraft work a
spacecraft works by using essentially
Newton's third law which says to every
you know every action there's an equal
and opposite reaction or alternatively
said if you take if you have your rocket
here and it has some some fuel inside
it's and propellants inside it a gas and
you eject that fuel out of the back of
the rocket at a high speed that will
that will push the rocket forwards and
there's a this is the idea of
conservation of momentum so if you have
the momentum is the mass times the
velocity so that's that's so you have a
certain amount of rocket fuel and you're
squirting it out of the back of the
rocket and you make that rocket fuel go
really really really fast then you'll be
able to have then that will push the
rocket forwards by an amount and the
rocket that that will what am I trying
to say
trying to explain why you can have it be
the case that a fairly small amount of
propellant you can store inside the
rocket can keep pushing the rocket
forwards for quite a while so to speak
um and but in order to get that
propellant pushed out of the back of the
rocket really quickly you need to have
you need to put a lot of energy into the
propellant you need to make it you need
to make the the rocket fuel go really
really fast and the way that's achieved
in a traditional rocket is through
combustion through essentially burning
so what you do is so as simple cases you
might have liquid hydrogen liquid oxygen
in two different tanks and the rocket
and then you bring those two together
and they there's a chemical reaction
between them which actually produces
water because that's eight water is h2o
and that's the that's the end result of
combining hydrogen and oxygen but the
process of going from separated hydrogen
and oxygen to water is one that releases
lots of energy
because essentially the hydrogen and
oxygen when they're when they're bound
together in a water molecule they are
and they have that binding energy you
sort of trade-off the binding energy for
for actual energy of kinetic energy when
you produce the water molecule and so on
but but but in I mean what's what's
basically happening in your average
rocket engine is you're combining some
fuel
together with some with something you're
essentially burning something like
you're burning the hydrogen in the
oxygen or you're burning some solid fuel
in something like oxygen and that's a
chemical reaction which releases energy
and usually the big challenge in a
rocket is you've got this combustion
chamber usually spherical combustion
chamber you've got a nozzle at the back
usually the big challenges can you get
fuel into that combustion chamber fast
enough to actually produce you know to
actually have the combustion run really
quickly and have the fuel come out of
the back of the rocket fast enough and
usually there's usually a turbo pump
that is trying to pump fuel into the
combustion chamber that's usually what
limits the efficiency of rockets is how
how fast you can pump stuff into this
combustion chamber and it's very
complicated
you know you see a typical rocket engine
it's full of all these weird tubes going
at all different places because the
actual the the properties of these gases
as they combust change change a lot
depending on their exact pressure and
temperature and so on and you have to
kind of take account of that and have
all these valves that control all sorts
of things and that that's kind of why
it's hard to make a rocket engine but
basically the idea of a rocket engine is
you're you're you're making you're
generating energy by by essentially
burning things and you know the nozzle
of the back actually that the nozzle is
sort of opening out because turns out
there's a weird property when you have a
gas that is traveling at hypersonic
speeds maybe more than 10 times the
speed of sound it actually normally with
the gas you think if you want to make it
go faster put it in a smaller more
constricted area but for hypersonic
gases it actually works the other way
around which is why you can give it you
can make it go a little bit faster by by
sort of opening it out like that but
anyway so standard rocket combustion of
chemical combustion produces high speed
gas that shoots out the back of the
rocket okay so what other methods could
use to make to to do something like that
well one thing you could do there are
things called ion rockets and the idea
of an ion rocket is you have a source of
electrons or ions atoms that have had
their electrons stripped off but they're
there so they're electrically charged
and you you have a you have something
which attracts because I mentioned you
know when you have let's say you have a
negatively charged to a plate here and
you have a source of positive ions here
then the negatively charged plate will
attract the positive ions if this is a
grill or something where they can go
through you you go you have the source
of ions they go through they thick sort
of attracted to this plate or this grill
then they go through the grill and they
get they get sent out the other side and
you can make a rocket engine that way
because you're essentially using
electrical forces to go and accelerate
the the electrons or ions or whatever
they they and then they they get
accelerated and pushed out the back of
the rocket and actually people make
small thrusters for rockets using ion
engines and just like you use up sort of
the hydrogen or oxygen or whatever it is
in liquid you know in propellant in a
standard chemical rocket in an ion
rocket you're using up whatever your
source of electrons or ions or whatever
it is to to make that that thing that's
that's pushed out of the back of the
rocket okay so what other kinds of ways
could you make a rocket well one way you
can make a rocket is with nuclear power
and there was a big thing in the 1960s
people thought nuclear rockets might
really be a big thing um the you know
nuclear power involves taking the
nucleus of an atom and for example using
the fact that well being we were able to
run the nucleus of an atom of a
sufficiently heavy element like uranium
comes apart it releases energy in doing
so and so and that happens you can in an
atomic bomb that happens very rapidly in
a nuclear power station that happens in
a much more controlled way the
equivalent of a nuclear power station is
used in in submarines for example where
there are nuclear submarines which are
powered by having a nuclear reactor and
the nuclear reactor has a small amount
of fuel uranium plutonium typically and
the the what's happening is there are
those those nuclei are kind of falling
apart as they fall apart the the the
products of them falling apart cause
other nuclei to fall apart and that
produces this kind of chain reaction
that in in the case of a nuclear power
station or a nuclear submarine is a
controlled nuclear reaction but it
releases energy and so it's using up
small numbers of atoms every atom that
it kind of uses up produces a certain
amount of energy but it's a actually a
very large amount of energy compared to
the amount of energy that you would get
by having a chemical reaction producing
energy so another scheme is to you
nuclear nuclear power for rockets as I
say that was a that was kind of a thing
that people thought about in 1960s the
problem is it's sort of a super bad idea
to have well to have sort of serious
nuclear things particularly things that
can turn into nuclear weapons in in
Earth orbit because well a very bad
thing happens if you detonated a nuclear
explosion in space it's never really
been done but it's been there been
definitions in the in the 1950s there
were there were nuclear explosions that
were detonated over the Pacific at a
decent height but not not all the way in
space um but um if you detonate a
nuclear explosion in space the the thing
that happens okay so so the definite
nuclear explosion in the atmosphere you
are producing your kind of exploding and
you're pushing the air away and you're
making a shock front from the air being
pushed away well in in space there's
nothing to make a shock front out of is
it's just a vacuum so that's not what
happens what happens instead is that you
have a lot of radiation that can be it's
it's light it's x-rays it's gamma rays
it's any kind of electromagnetic
radiation gets produced by this nuclear
explosion and that all streams outwards
from remember the explosion happened but
one of the things that's produced is not
only light and x-rays and gamma rays and
so on but also radio waves intense radio
waves and in particular this thing
called the EMP electromagnetic pulse
which is kind of an intense sort of
one-shot radio pulse and the the the
issue with that is it's it's a sort of
it's a very intense thing produced by
the nuclear explosion and any piece of
electronics that is sort of anywhere
near it when that radio pulse when that
very intense pulse goes through the
electronics it will essentially produce
something like that electric breakdown
that I was mentioning for lightning
before it will it will essentially
destroy that electronics by by
essentially produce
producing a voltage inside the
electronics just by virtue of the the
pulse goat the electromagnetic pulse
going through the electronics and will
destroy the electronics so if you have a
bunch of satellites as we do now and you
know whatever it is you know twenty
thousand satellites in Earth orbit or
something then and there's one
electromagnetic pulse produced by a
nuclear explosion then any satellite
that isn't shielded by being kind of in
the shadow of the earth basically it has
its electronics fried so that's a sort
of super bad thing happen that happens
in that case so that's that's one of one
of the kind of it's a bad idea to have
nuclear stuff in in in orbit and so
nuclear rockets haven't really been much
of a thing I should say if you're the
the deep-space probes the ones that went
to for example outside the solar system
the Voyager and pioneer space pioneer
ten eleven that went out of the solar
system it's now like is it 30 times the
distance from now how far is it I've
forgotten it's some those are the the
things that humans have made that have
gone farthest so they've been they've
been going for like um nearly forty
years now um the going out from the Sun
out out of there out of the solar system
by now um but one of the questions is
how did they get power because usually
you know satellites they typically have
solar panels they're getting light
they're getting power from from light
but when you're far far away from the
Sun that doesn't work anymore and so
what was done for those deep-space
probes was they used what's called
thermal radio well they they basically
use the fact that radioactive decay
produces Heat it's not a nuclear
reaction in the sense of something where
there's a chain reaction where one
nuclear disintegration produces another
nuclear disintegration a big chain like
in a nuclear reactor or a nuclear
explosion instead it's just every
individual nuclear decay that just
happens spontaneously in any radioactive
material produces a certain amount of
heat and so what these things had was
radioisotope they were they were
where where they had this this
radioactive material that was um that
was put into the into the spacecraft
it's actually out typically on an arm so
that doesn't so that the radiation from
the radioactive decays doesn't affect
the electronics in the main part of the
spacecraft but um it's and it uses the
heat that comes from that radioactivity
to to users then converts that heat and
electricity to power the spacecraft okay
so anyway that that's some but that's
not not nuclear reaction not it's just
spontaneous nuclear decay that's used
for that okay let's go back to the Star
Trek type thing so there's another level
of kind of use of nuclear like stuff
that you could do which is to use
matter-antimatter annihilation so I
think I mentioned on another one of
these live streams that the idea of
antimatter so to every particle like a
proton there is also a particle called
an antiproton that is the opposite that
has the opposite charge to a proton as
the same mass because mass is always
positive but the charge of an antiproton
is minus the charge of an ordinary
proton you bring a proton and antiproton
together they will annihilate each other
they'll produce a bunch of other
particles typically a bunch of photons
things called pi ons various other
things maybe some electrons and
positrons as well but they'll they'll
annihilate so all of the all of the
energy that's tied up in the mass of
these protons gets gets turned into war
energy so it's a very efficient way of
taking if you could get enough
antimatter to do this you would have a
little bottle of antimatter and you
would you would take that bottle of
antimatter and you would combine it with
matter and they will annihilate each
other producing a bunch of energy okay
so one of the questions is how do you
get antimatter well there is a certain
amount of antimatter produced in
particle accelerators you can get the
easiest antimatter to produces
antielectrons to called positrons and
the most common way to do that is you
you if you if you sort of make an
intense x-ray you shine it in a material
you will get the you'll get electron
positron pairs made electrons and
positrons as a pair get made and then
you can sort of capture the positrons
like you can you can filter them off by
using a magnetic field because in a
magnetic field the particles with
different with opposite charges will go
in opposite directions so you can kind
of filter off the positrons so in big
particle accelerators one of the goals
is to have a beam made all the positrons
and that's done by essentially creating
the positrons filtering them off and
then arranging them with magnets to go
in this beam actually this sort of the
fanciest thing is antek protons and the
biggest particle accelerator in the
world the LHC in Geneva Switzerland it
has a beam of protons inside it and also
has a beam of anti protons and it's a
big engineering adventure to basically
produce anti protons you produce them as
proton antiproton pairs and then to
filter off the anti protons to what's
called cool the anti protons so they're
not all going in random directions but
they're all going that one direction you
want them to go in and the beam ranty
protons and then you accelerate the anti
protons around this big circular ring
that's a few miles across that that is
the particle accelerator but anyway so
the result is there's a small number of
anti protons that are produced there and
okay so how do you keep if you have
symantec protons let's say I had a
bottle of anti protons how would I keep
a bottle of anti protons because as soon
as I have a as soon as I have you know
if I just put them in a metal box that
metal box contains a bunch of protons
because that's what's inside the atoms
that make up the metal box and so as
soon as what any of my anti protons come
into contact with protons BAM they
annihilate and you know no more anti
protons so how do you keep anti protons
in a box you know what kind of box can
you keep them in well there's one kind
of box that will work which is
essentially a magnetic box because
photons don't it's basically because
photons are their own antiparticles
photons an anti photon is just a photon
um and and photons are what in a sense
make electromagnetic things and so you
can you can imagine something we have a
bunch of magnetic fields where you're
kind of keeping these antek protons in
this kind of magnetic bottle where
there's no material as no atoms or
anything that that are inside it's just
it's kind of like a force field but it
only works that force field only works
for these particles these anti protons
that have a definite electric charge
if you ever threw something in there
that had a different electric charge the
force field wouldn't work anymore for it
but this this when you just have these
these anti protons in there you can make
a magnetic bottle that keeps the anti
protons in there so kind of in the in
the Star Trek concept it's kind of like
you keep a bottle of antiprotons and
you're gradually letting those anti
protons out and letting them annihilate
with protons and bam that makes a lot of
energy every time that annihilation
happens now having said that you might
say has anybody actually made a bottle
of antiprotons the answer is not really
they've made ones with a very small
number of anti protons this whole
process of confining things with
magnetic fields is a very difficult
process and so that's not really been a
big thing that's been done but it's but
it's certainly in principle possible
okay we've got all kinds of questions
here let me take a look at a few of
these here
okay there's a question here about Tim
are there universe hacks that can be
done based on on my on our sort of
emerging model of how fundamental
physics works don't know yet been
wondering about it my guess is the
places where there might be quotes
universe hacks have to do with things to
do with quantum computers some possibly
the space tunnels thing possibly some
things to do with particles that are
much lighter than electrons and that
kind of go through every every kind of
material and so on that's that's the
that's the current thinking but I think
it's a it's it's kind of a it's a bit of
a challenging thing because if you
started off from I don't know the early
theories of gravity from 300 years ago
and you said what are the gravity hacks
that you might might be able to
implement to do with you know having you
know spacecraft that are going to other
planets were these complicated maneuvers
where they slingshot around Jupiter or
something to get enough momentum to go
out to other planets I don't think one
would have had those ideas in the first
few weeks after the original after
Newton's universal gravitation idea
emerge so these are things that that
have to develop after one really
understands these theories better
let's see questions about some
extraterrestrials let me come back to
that if we if we it's a slightly
complicated answer I think um okay
there's a question here do I think an
organism living its whole life in
three-dimensional space could survive
entering a high dimensional area I
wondered about that I have a I her bad
feeling that it's impossible I have a
bad feeling that that if you are you
know if you were a creature that lived
on a two-dimensional plane um maybe you
can keep going sort of living in that
two-dimensional plane even in
three-dimensional space and maybe the
same thing could happen if you're you
know if there's some space tunnel that's
a a six dimensional space tunnel or
something and we're just these poor
three-dimensional critters um I'm not
sure though and I have a slightly bad
feeling about that but that might not
work I mean because what happens in in
black holes for example is you tend to
get there are they're very strong
gravitational fields and what's worse a
gravitational field would like pull you
into the center of the black hole but
there's a much worse thing that happens
which is the tidal forces so what
happens is the you know if you're if
you've got your heads going that way and
your tails that way so to speak the you
know your head is and here's the here's
the center of the black hole you know
your your head is close to the center of
the black hole your your feet are
further away from the center of the
black hole the force of gravity on your
head is proportionately because you're
closer to the black hole is stronger
than the force of gravity in your feet
and so what that will tend to do is to
elongate you in the direction of the of
the in which that you're being pulled
and that happens on the earth for
example the gravity of the moon will
make if you look at the oceans on the
earth there that's why it's called tidal
forces the oceans on the earth the the
the water that is on the side of the
earth that's closer to the moon is
proportionately pulled further up and
the water that's on the on the on the
earth the opposite side from the moon is
sort of goes further away and that term
so
in effect the earth is getting slightly
elongated by the presence of the moon
actually that happens both of the oceans
on the earth and there's also things
called solid tides which are a
deformation in the actual shape of the
earth and the rock and the earth as a
result of that gravitational effect but
that effect gets very strong around a
black hole and so the the technical term
I think in in the black hole business is
spaghettification everything gets turned
into kind of long pieces of spaghetti
because everything is elongated it's
sort of infinitely elongated but between
its its its head and its feet so to
speak so things like that might happen
um
let's see
gosh a lot of interesting questions here
hold on hold on let me just read through
here and just get um
okay that's a there's a sophisticated
nann kid discussion here about space
tunnels and sheafs of gd6 and space
tunnels which looks interesting but let
me not some may not go there right now
okay there questions about teleportation
you
okay yeah okay so um lots of intro
questions here let's see
let's talk about well talk about the end
of the universe for a moment so we don't
know what the what the end result so the
universe is expanding and the right now
we don't know whether the rate of
expansion of the universe is going to
stay constant whether it's going to
eventually decrease maybe even turn
around and the universe could start
contracting again whether the expansion
of the universe is going to get
progressively faster we people have been
trying to measure that in recent times
and there's a slight suggestion that the
universe is accelerating in its
expansion now it's a little bit the you
know why does it accelerate actually it
has to do with the whole negative mass
business that I was talking about
earlier there's a there's this thing
called dark energy which is kind of a a
way of describing the fact that the
universe sort of behaves as if there's
negative mass everywhere in the universe
um it's just slightly it slightly weird
thing and it really just sort of feeds
into a bunch of mathematical equations
but you know the question is what's
eventually going to happen in the
universe is the universe eventually
going to you know what will what will
happen I mean our our you know the
universe is so far about fifteen billion
years old the earth is about four
four-and-a-half billion years old the
Sun might survive another five I think
five to ten billion years um eventually
will turn into a white dwarf star um it
won't do anything terribly violent it
won't have a giant supernova explosion
it won't turn into a black hole it's not
um it'll just sort of quietly sort of
fizzle out and turn into a white dwarf
um but um the the thing that so the
question is what will happen sort of in
a very very very long term of the
universe billions of years in the future
um and so one of the things that's
happening in our galaxy is our galaxy
has about a hundred billion stars in it
at the center of our galaxy there's a
giant garbage dump basically there's a
giant black hole I think it's about one
hundred thousand solar masses and mass
right now I think it's it's um it's a
it's a black
all right it's maybe slightly less than
that um it's uh it's a black hole that's
slowly absorbing stars and so it's it's
like it's like garbage disposal at the
center of the galaxy
um and so over time eventually more and
more stars will fall into that black
hole at the center of our galaxy and
presumably over time more and more of
the universe will just turn into a bunch
of giant black holes now um and and
presumably as the universe well okay so
in the scenario where the universe keeps
expanding that's probably what will
happen now there's a there's a little
footnote to that which is that but
because of this thing I mentioned called
Hawking radiation black holes eventually
evaporate eventually a black hole even
though you thought black holes just
absorb things actually as a result of
quantum effects and as a matter of fact
one could see this very beautifully in
this new theory of ours how this works
as a result of of quantum processes
there's a slow rate of particles coming
out of black holes as well as things
going into black holes so in the in the
very distant future these black holes
will of that are sort of formed from
Centers of galaxies will eventually
evaporate and they'll produce a bunch of
material of a bunch of a bunch of
particles in the universe and what will
happen to those particles is not
completely clear those particles might
be subject to the force of gravity and
they might start forming a new
generation of stars and galaxies and
other things not completely clear um the
okay so right now in the current
measurements okay so it's one
possibility is that the that sort of
universe gets very boring and it's very
very quiet and it's just a bunch of
black holes eventually the black holes
evaporate then things might happen
another generation of stuff might happen
another possibility is that the universe
will will sort of slow down and
eventually start contracting again and
the universe started from a big bang at
the beginning maybe it ends up with a
big crunch at the end and it's sort of
reprocessed
all the stuff in the universe is kind of
reprocessed and another kind of BIGBANG
after that a little bit like what's
happening these black holes where things
come in they sort of get reprocessed in
the black holes and eventually get
emitted again it's walking radiation so
the other possibility is that the
universe is is progressively
accelerating and that eventually the
universe is that that there's the the
edges of the universe are going faster
than the speed of light and how that
works
I said nothing can go faster than light
it's slightly complicated because one
has to ask the question how does one
know sort of what what time it is where
in the universe and when you unravel all
that you realize that um you the the
sort of if you were to look from outside
the universe you might see it expanding
faster than light but from inside the
universe you never detect that
phenomenon so you can't kind of use so
you can't hitch yourself you know you
can't hitchhike on the expansion in the
universe so to speak to do that but you
know what happens in this accelerating
thing is that that sort of things
eventually become so dispersed in the
universe that's sort of nothing really
nothing can kind of communicate with
anything else well um yeah so there's a
question here would it be possible for
intelligent species to create the
conditions to create a new universe oh
this is a complicated story because okay
what we currently believe in our theory
is that the universe is ultimately a
computational thing the universe is
running these rules that just say but
just say how space is created how
everything else is created but the
difference between like running those
rules in a computer that we've
constructed and the universe running
those rules is is quite a big difference
because you know we could run those
rules we can simulate what the universe
would do but what is going on in the
actual universe is it has actualized
those rules it's it's it is behaving
according to those rules it's not that
it's running those rules on a computer
it's just those rules are describing how
the universe works and the universe is
working according to those rules
so you can ask questions like given the
rules for the universe can you sort of
reimplemented of the universe like you
re implement them in a computer could
you reimplemented some other part of the
universe so that you effectively have a
simulation of the universe running
inside the universe the answer is yes
you can imagine doing that you will in
any way I can imagine doing that you
lose unbelievable amounts of you know of
like it might be you know 10 to the 100
times slower to do the simulated
universe as compared to the actual
universe um so you know I think that
that's um so I I'm I'm kind of the
question of how do you create something
you know I I think in the in our theory
of how the universe works the universe
just follows a certain rule and it just
does what it does and everything about
what's happening in the universe is in a
sense determined by that rule I mean
they know the words I'm saying now is
sort of ultimately determined by the
rule that runs the universe and you
don't really have any choice about that
it's just the universe is going to do
what the universe does we don't get to
sort of be outside it and ever change
what it does it is inexorably going to
do what it does now how we choose to
exist in that universe is a whole
different story so for example you know
somebody was asking earlier about sort
of the long-term future of humanity and
you know right now we exist as kind of
you know biological organisms with
electrical signals in our brains that
cause us to think things and so on and
so on and so on but it's not clear that
if you want sort of the essence whatever
the essence of sort of human
consciousness or whatever is it's not
clear that the only implementation
medium for that is humans with biology
and brains and things like that now you
might say what does it mean to be a
human if you don't have you know your
whole sort of biological body around not
clear it's not you know I think that's
something that we'll get worked out
probably in the next
hundred years or so and the trajectory
were on right now as it becomes so so
you know the thoughts that go on in our
brains are essentially encoded in
electrical signals in the nerve cells in
our brains and there is a those that
pattern of thoughts is something that we
could you know we could run it on a
computer we can do all kinds of things
with it that pattern of thoughts is not
specifically tied into the particular
biological implementation with our you
know nerve cells that are using glucose
to fuel themselves and a you know doing
all these kinds of things that are all
of what we are used to doing in biology
there is a sense in which that pattern
of electrical activity is just
represented by you know a bunch of bits
of information that are representing how
we're thinking about things so you know
people imagine in kind of a sort of
science-fiction way this notion of
uploading human consciousness to a
machine so you know my our brains have
about a hundred billion neurons probably
in them it's kind of hard to tell
exactly how many because because they're
very mushy and it's very hard to count
neurons because they're very long
spindly things with a lot of connections
to a lot of places but roughly it's a
hundred billion and our and the these
neurons are all very interconnected
they're maybe maybe a hundred trillion
connections between all these neurons in
our brains so and presumably we don't
know absolutely for sure but it looks
super likely that all of our memories
everything about sort of who we are is
encoded in the in those connections so
those hundred trillion connections are
representing each one of those
connections has a certain has a sort of
a bit of information associated with it
and so we're kind of storing maybe a
terabyte of information in our brains
that represents sort of all of our
memories and all the things that we we
do to sort of figure out to have our
brains operate and you know that so that
that's kind of the the the computational
structure that corresponds to our brains
now imagine that we implement that
computational structure not using
biology but using some other medium like
digital computers you know we're we're
we're not that far away from being able
to simulate what happens in a brain
we're maybe maybe a thousand times maybe
ten thousand times away depending on
exactly how how efficient or inefficient
brains our brains are probably pretty
inefficient compared to what we could
create with it with modern engineering
and so on but so unlike for example it's
worth realizing that our neurons in our
brains the winner when a signal goes
from one neuron to another it takes
maybe a millisecond or something a
thousandth of a second whereas when a
signal goes from one part of a computer
to another it takes a billionth of a
second a million so it's going a million
times faster than the stuff in our
brains so it's not clear quite how far
away from being able to sort of emulate
what's in brains we really are and you
know it's also not clear the the details
so people make in an AI on freshly
intelligent systems people make these
things that are called neural networks
which are kind of a simple computational
idealization of the way that actual
neural networks work in brains and it
looked like they were a pretty bad
idealization they weren't a really good
model for how actual neurons work but
actually turns out doesn't seem to
matter much but it isn't a good model
the same kinds of learning processes
that happen in actual brains with actual
neurons seem to be able to happen in
these artificial neurons even though the
artificial neurons are a are not really
emulating all the details of how how our
brains neurons and our brains work so
it's quite possible that the kinds of
even artificial neurons that we have
right now could be able to be sort of
the the carriers of activity that are
like the activity that goes on in our
brains and so you know one question is
okay I'm gonna make I'm gonna make the
the the the digital version of me you
know the the the me bot how do I do that
well you know you kind of have to
presumably it would have to learn
through all the kinds of experiences
that
you know that I have and so on it would
have to see you know we'd have to learn
just like oh there's a mentioning this
at the beginning here I mean there's a
certain amount of built-in information
in our brains there's certain about a
built-in structure in our brains the the
way like the visual cortex that the back
of our brain works the the details of
seeing seeing a cat or a dog
those are not built-in but the overall
structure of the visual cortex is
determined by the way our brains are
built and the overall fact that you know
there's some places well actually even
that is not quite so built in but there
there's features of the of the visual
cortex that are that are sort of built
in as a matter of the construction of
the nerve cells that aren't things that
are learnt by us in our lives um but um
but ignoring that much of what's there
is just learnt from the course of our
lives so sort of a question is if you're
gonna make a digital bot of yourself how
much information do you need to do that
I mean I've kind of wondered for myself
you know as I record all these live
streams and I you know I've recorded my
email for thirty years more than thirty
years now and I've recorded all the
keystrokes I type and all sorts of
things like that just because I think
it's it's fun to keep all that data um
you know there's a question of you know
is that in fact enough data to reproduce
me if you had a a neural net and so on
or some system that was big enough
could you just play back my email
experience for the last 30 years and
have something which say oh yeah I I've
learnt from what you know what Steven
does here and there you know I've
learned what what he does so I can kind
of reproduce what he does and then you
have something which is kind of the me
bot so to speak um and you know is that
possible I think thing I think that will
be possible um you know how much I think
that the and there'll be all kinds of
complicated questions there I mean in
other words you know I don't know you
know will I get home with my me BOTS
unclear I don't know I'm not sure I
would I would get on well with it with
an exact copy of myself and then there
are all kinds of questions like you know
people were talking about teleportation
you know it depends on
what form you know if to teleport a
material object is one thing to teleport
a digital representation of a brain is a
quite a different thing I mean by the
way it's worth realizing woman talks
about teleportation that there's one
thing is to take the atoms that are in
you and move them somewhere else but you
know every atom of hydrogen is the same
as every other atom of hydrogen and you
know all every electron is the same as
every other electron so this question of
how do you move something from here to
there well if you could say I'm gonna
deke I'm gonna figure out what what
where every atom in the thing that I've
got coming into my teleportation device
how every atom is arranged I'm gonna
take that information about how every
atom is arranged I'm gonna send it you
know I'm gonna send a light signal for
example the speed of light I'm gonna
send the signal that's just all this
data about how all those atoms are
arranged and at the other end I'm gonna
have a little device that reconstructs
where all those atoms are placed well
then you can have no material passed
from one place to the other but
nevertheless you had the result of going
from one place to another let's say at
the speed of light so now but you have
all kinds of weird questions like for
example if the device that was reading
the the thing coming in maybe it was a
brain maybe it was a frog maybe it was
who knows what it was you know reading
the thing coming in did it destroy the
thing coming in when it read it when it
figured out where every atom is if it
did then what it's going to look like is
you destroy the frog frog turns in you
just have a description of where all the
atoms on the frog are you you move that
description to another to somewhere else
and you reconstruct the frog that's
model number one model number two you
have a very clever way of reading out
where all the atoms in the frog are and
actually at the end of it you have two
frogs one at the you know one where it
came from and one where it's where it
was reconstructed at the other end so
there a lot of weird questions about
what will we think about that for
example for humans a lot of
weird questions about human identity and
so on that come up and you know there
will be a lot of questions about whether
sort of disembodied human consciousness
is what kinds of you know to what extent
they are like the human and to what
extent they should have rights like
humans and things like this to what
extent are they merely a merely sort of
the creation of the human and not don't
have the same character as the human
themselves and there are a lot of lot of
interesting questions there and a lot of
a lot of things about some you know if
you have a disembodied human
consciousness is it okay to destroy it
if even if it could never be
reconstructed is that is that a terrible
thing to do or not well it's just a
bunch of bits and right now erasing a
hard disk in the normal course of events
it's like you know nobody thinks it's
it's well it might be it might be that
there's something on the hard disk that
you really want to keep but but Tim you
know it's it's some it doesn't have
quite the same characteristic as as you
know getting rid of a human it's some
it's just like oh well we erased that
data um so anyway okay I'll take one or
two more questions here and then I
should wrap up and go try and figure out
stuff about our actual universe yeah I
think this question of
consciousness and you know this kind of
uploaded human consciousness and whether
that's the end point for us humans I
mean that's an interesting question and
you know I think there's a certain
inevitability to that I think that there
is a big question if you are going to
sort of exist as a simulated
consciousness in a you know in this in
the sort of inside this this kind of
computer what do you choose to do with
yourself because you know we all get
motivated to do the things we do for
different reasons but a lot of those
motivations are a detailed consequence
of the the you know the way that we lead
our lives today as you know humans
walking around eating things you know
you know living dying etc um it's it's a
you know it's a it's a very the way that
we get motivated to do things is a
consequence of the sort of cultural
environment in which we find ourselves
and if our cultural environment is we're
in this kind of digital box as a
simulated consciousness it's not clear
what the motivations are for it so for
example you know a lot of what happens
there's a lot of kind of things that are
driven by the scarcity resources in the
world the fact that they're you know the
fact that something can be of higher
value because there's less of it and
people are prepared to pay more money to
get that thing when there's less of it
I'm in a situation where everything is
just digital that that type of scarcity
would exist only in a very different way
and I think sort of a bunch of questions
about how does you know does human
society effectively is human society to
what extent is human society dependent
on the existence of you know a limited
amount of you know limited human life
spans limited numbers of humans limited
you know all sorts of other
characteristics of you know people
having you know to what extent this does
does the current set of human
motivations and the current structure of
human society depend on those
very physical constraints and to what
extent is it's sort of an inevitable
logical consequence of just having
entities that that exists together so if
we don't but it might be the case that
as soon as you have entities that exists
together you will have a there's you
know you might have I don't know it's
kind of hard to imagine you know well
the sort of might be preferred real
estate because it might be well I want
to be in this part of this virtual space
that's nearer my friends and I can only
have a certain number of them just
because not because of the structure of
the the kind of the virtual space but
because for example I can only I can
only process the information associated
with having you know ten good friends
and so if the the eleventh person wants
to come and be a good friend well I
can't do that because I can't process
the information associated with that and
if I could process the information I you
know so there's a sort of a complicated
circularity to how you think about
whether sort of the structure whether
certain features of human society are
dependent on on the details of of the
way that our actual physical world works
or not I mean it's you know back in the
day when people were thinking about
money for example there was a long
period of time in human history
where money was where you know one
dollar meant you could go to the bank of
the country and say give me a piece of
gold that is you know that dollar you
gave me is just a thing that says I'm
entitled to get a piece of gold from you
and for a long time people sort of
thought that money fundamentally had to
be backed by actual gold that was worth
that had some scarcity and was worth
something and then it was realized that
actually money is a much more abstract
thing that doesn't have to be backed by
actual physical stuff like gold that's
worth something
so there's a question and you know as
one thinks about kind of the structure
of society to what extent of the things
that we currently imagine are tied to
certain kinds of physicality really
things that are tied to physicality or
not I mean like for example if your
creating of democracy and you say you
know one-person one-vote okay great so
now imagine that we've got digital
consciousnesses and every digital
consciousness can make a thousand copies
of itself okay or a million copies of
itself well then this you know
one-person one-vote it's like how does
that work you know this thing just made
a million copies oh that were made a
billion copies how does that work well I
suspect that in that particular case
that in the end that unravels itself and
it doesn't really matter that you can
make all these copies but then you know
I'll give you another example of
something it gets really tricky is right
now we have the notion of there is a
definite notion of a person you know
there's a there's an entity which is a
person and it's not it's not kind of a
nose either there is a person or there
isn't a person there oh there is a
person responsible for that oh that
though there isn't so to speak but you
know when you imagine these sort of
digital analogues of people it's a
little less clear whether it's person or
no person it's you know can there be
kind of a a sort of a a pseudo person a
fractional person so to speak and how
does that work
and you know then then a lot of the
structure of counting doesn't work
anymore for people and there's there's
that's just so it's a quite an
interesting thing to try to imagine you
know what does what aspects of society
depend on physicality and what are sort
of inevitable you know there are there
are features of I don't know voting
systems and things that might be quite
abstractly work that way or certain
aspects of economics that may completely
abstractly work that way
independent of any physicality I don't
think we really know which one's work
which way all right I think we should
wrap up there well this was fun for me I
hope people found this interesting it's
you know usually one of the downsides of
doing science is we have a particular
universe that we've been throwing and
when you do science you're trying to
sort of unravel how that particular
universe works
what sort of fun about about sort of the
science fiction idea is you you get to
say you know well even an hour you know
what's logically possible even an
opponent of our universe or the
the way that we exist in our universe
the way that we you know we existed a
certain size and and time scale and so
on on our universe all right well I
should wrap up there so thanks a lot and
I I hope well next week I'll pick a
slightly different topic and we can talk
about that and please do give us
feedback and you know I have fun doing
these things but let us know what works
and what doesn't
thanks a lot okay bye bye have a good
weekend